>>> FROM AN OBSCURE LEGAL
ACADEMIC TO ENABLER IN CHIEF,
JOHN EASTMAN HAD A SWIFT RISE TO
BECOME ONE OF THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL VOICE IN TRUMP'S
ORBIT PRIOR TO THEN SUR
RECOLLECTION.
JOINING IS MAGGIE HABERMAN,
WASHINGTON CORRESPONDENT FOR THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" WHO HAD A
TERRIFIC ARTICLE OUT OVER THE
WEEK.
A LAWYER TRUMP FOUND ON FOX
NEWS.
>> RIGHT.
>> ONCE HE FOUND HIM AND BROUGHT
HIM INTO THE ORBIT, TALK ABOUT
THE TIMELINE, THE LITERAL
BLUEPRINT FOR OVERTHROWING AN
ELECTION.
.
>> SO, IT'S FASCINATING WHEN
EASTMAN SAID HE WAS ASKED BY
TRUMP TO WRITE THIS MEMO.
BECAUSE IT WAS AROUND CHRISTMAS
LAST YEAR.
NOW, THAT IS AFTER THE ELECTORS
ARE GOING FOR JOE BIDEN AND WE
KNOW THIS.
THAT'S THE DECEMBER 14th DATE.
DECEMBER 18th, A WILD MEETING IN
THE OVAL OFFICE I BROKE AT THE
TIME ABOUT SIDNEY POWELL AND
MIKE FLYNN ARE THERE WITH THE
CEO OF OVERSTOCK ARGUING THAT
TRUMP CAN ACTUALLY SEIZE THE
VOTING MACHINES AND RERUN THE
ELECTION.
HE DOESN'T GO WITH THAT.
A NUMBER OF ADVISERS WERE
ARGUING AGAINST IT.
IT WAS A VERY EMOTIONAL MEETING.
TRUMP, ACCORDING TO EASTMAN,
REACHES OUT AND SAYS, PLEASE
GIVE ME THIS, YOU KNOW, PLAN FOR
HOW YOU DO THIS.
NOW, TRUMP DOESN'T TYPICALLY ASK
FOR MEMOS THAT WAY.
SO I'M A LITTLE SKEPTICAL THAT
THE CONVERSATION WENT QUITE THAT
WAY.
BUT HE DOES PRODUCE THIS PIECE
OF PAPER, AND THAT BECAME THE
BASIS FOR WHAT TRUMP WAS USING
TO PUSH PENCE TO NOT CERTIFY THE
ELECTION FOR JOE BIDEN AND TO
CERTIFY IT FOR TRUMP.
THE THING ABOUT THE MEMO IS THE
ORIGINAL PLAN WAS THIS REQUIRED
ALTERNATE SLATES OF ELECTORS
FROM THESE STATES.
NO STATE PUT SUCH AN ALTERNATE
SLATE FORWARD.
SUDDENLY THE CONVERSATION A
COUPLE OF DAYS BEFOREHAND AND IN
A MEETING JANUARY 4th WITH
EASTMAN, TRUMP, PENCE, PENCE'S
COUNSEL AND CHIEF OF STAFF
BECOMES, WELL, CAN YOU DELAY IT.
THAT WAS CLEARLY THE BACKUP
PLAN.
.
>> A MAN WHO WROTE A BLUEPRINT
FOR HOW TO OVERFLOW AN ELECTION
IS STILL VERY MUCH INVOLVED WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
.
>> HE IS STILL TALKING TO HIM.
HE IS ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO IS
STILL IN HIS ORBIT.
I THINK HE WOULD LIKE TO BE MORE
INVOLVED THAN HE IS.
TRUMP WITH A WIDE ARRAY OF LEGAL
MATTERS BEFORE HIM.
THE INNER CIRCLE IS DIFFUSED
RIGHT NOW.
HE HAS NOT BEEN BANISHED LIKE,
SAY, SIDNEY POWELL IS.
.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING THE FORMER PRESIDENT
SAID ABOUT RON DeSANTIS.
HE HAS BEEN CIRCUMSPECT WHEN
ASKED ABOUT 2024 OPPONENTS.
IF I FACED HIM, RON DeSANTIS,
I'D BEAT HIM LIKE I WOULD BEAT
EVERYONE ELSE.
I DON'T THINK I WOULD FACE HIM.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE WOULD DROP
OUT.
I THINK HE WOULD DROP OUT.
>> IT'S FASCINATING TO ME THAT
HE ADDRESSED IT THIS WAY FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS.
HE'S BEEN PRETTY CAREFUL ABOUT
WHAT HE SAID, NOT JUST ABOUT THE
OTHER CANDIDATES BUT ABOUT
DeSANTIS.
HE HAS BEEN -- NOT GINGERLY BUT
BARELY GONE THERE.
HE IS HEEDING WHAT SOME OF HIS
OWN ADVISERS ARE SAYING.
DeSANTIS MAY RUN AGAINST YOU
EVEN IF YOU DECIDE TO RUN.
DOES TRUMP RUN, NUMBER ONE.
IF HE DOES, DOES ANYONE ELSE
CHALLENGE HIM?
HE IS CLEARLY LAYING DOWN A
MARKER WITH DeSANTIS HERE.
.
>> I WONDER WHAT DeSANTIS WOULD
DO.
>> I DOUBT THAT HE WOULD
CHALLENGE TRUMP, BUT HE PROBABLY
DOESN'T LIKE BEING BOXED IN THIS
WAY.
.
>> TWITTER HAS BANNED HIM.
AND IN INTERVIEWS AND
DISCUSSIONS HE LIKES TO SAY, HE
DOESN'T MISS TWITTER AT ALL.
HE LIKES THE FREE TIME.
NEVERTHELESS, HE'S ASKING A
FEDERAL JUDGE TO FORCE TWITTER
TO GET HIM BACK ON.
>> RIGHT.
PEOPLE WHO ARE ENJOYING RESPITE
FOR SOCIAL MEDIA AREN'T FIGHTING
TO GET BACK ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE WHAT HE IS
SAYING ABOUT HIS NEW STATEMENT
PLAN.
IT RAISES AN INTERESTING
QUESTION.
TWITTER BANNED HIM WE KNOW AFTER
JANUARY 6th.
IF HE ISN'T A CANDIDATE NEXT
TIME, I'M SURE THEY'RE GOING TO
STICK WITH THAT.
IF HE IS A CANDIDATE NEXT TIME,
THEY'RE GOING TO COME UNDER
ENORMOUS PRESSURE TO PUT HIM
BACK ON AND HOW THEY RESPOND TO
THAT IS GOING TO BE PRETTY
INTERESTING.
.
>> THAT'S A TWITTER THING MORE
THAN A TRUMP THING.
.
>> 100%.
BUT THE IMPACT IS GOING TO BE
THE SAME.
.
>> I WANT TO ASK ABOUT HIS
FORMER CAMPAIGN MANAGER, COREY
LEWANDOWSKI.
HE HAS BEEN BASICALLY PUSHED OUT
BECAUSE OF AN INTERACTION HE HAD
WITH A FUND-RAISER.
THIS IS TRISHELLE ODOM.
HE REPEATEDLY TOUCHED ME,
STALKED ME AND MADE ME FEEL
VIOLATED AND FEARFUL.
I'M COMING FORWARD BECAUSE HE
NEEDS TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
HE'S BEEN PUSHED ASIDE FROM THE
SUPER PAC.
>> ONE NOTE OF CLARITY.
THEY'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
PUSHING HIM OUT.
THEY TECHNICALLY CAN'T OVERSEE
PERSONNEL CHANGES OF THE SUPER
PAC.
AS FAR AS I UNDERSTAND IT,
LEWANDOWSKY IS NOT GOING
WILLINGLY.
I THINK WE WILL SEE MORE ON
THAT.
IN TERMS OF WHY THIS, AS YOU AND
I KNOW, FIVE YEARS OF PEOPLE
AROUND TRUMP TRYING TO SEPARATE
TRUMP FROM LEWANDOWSKY.
I'M NOT CONVINCED THIS IS THE
END OF LEWANDOWSKY, JUST WITH
THIS MONEY AT LEAST IN TRUMP
LAND.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO FOCUS ON HIS OUTSIDE
CLIENTS AND SUGGESTED HE WAS
MISHANDLING THAT OR SORT OF
MAKING HIMSELF THE FACE OF
ACCESS TO TRUMP IN CHANGE -- NOT
EXCHANGE BUT THE ABILITY TO GET
OTHER CLIENTS IN SERVICE OF
HIMSELF.
ALMOST EVERYONE HAS THEIR OWN
CLIENTS AT THIS POINT.
THAT'S NOT UNUSUAL THAT PEOPLE
HAVE ZEROED IN ON THAT.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE OF SAYING
IT ON THE RECORD.
BUT IT'S PEOPLE TRYING TO
BASICALLY, YOU KNOW, WARN TRUMP
THAT IF YOU RUN AGAIN, THERE ARE
GOING TO BE THESE DISTRACTIONS,
AND THIS CAN'T BE ONE.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS MOVIE BEFORE
WITH OTHER STAFF.
MAYBE NOT TO THIS DEGREE.
THE THIN